todo
hola hoy en saint si la relatividad
general
qué es la gravitación la gravitación o
gravedad es un fenómeno fundamental en
el universo que tiende a acercar objetos
entre sí
si la manzana queda al suelo la luna
órbita alrededor de la tierra y la
tierra orbita alrededor del sol esto se
debe a la gravedad que actúa entre los
objetos e impide que se alejen unos de
otros
a primera vista se podría pensar que la
gravitación es una fuerza que actúa
trayendo los objetos en función de su
masa
cuanto más masivo sea un objeto más
atraer a otros cuerpos del universo
hacia él
esta representación de la gravedad como
fuerza nos permite entender el
comportamiento de los objetos al caer
o la forma en que los planetas giran
alrededor del sol
sin embargo en la vida real ciertos
indicios sutiles evidencian que la
gravitación no es realmente una fuerza
por ejemplo cuando observamos un
satélite que cae hacia la tierra si la
gravedad fuese una fuerza debería caer
directo hacia el centro del planeta
pero cuando realizamos este experimento
vemos que su trayectoria está
ligeramente curvada siguiendo la
dirección de la rotación de la tierra
[Música]
otro indicio es el hecho de que la
órbita de mercurio cambia de orientación
con cierta velocidad a medida que
transcurre el tiempo
si la gravedad fuese una fuerza
podríamos predecir con exactitud la
velocidad con la que debería cambiar
esta órbita sin embargo lo que se
observa es que la órbita cambia con una
velocidad un tanto diferente
[Música]
si tenemos en cuenta estos sutiles
indicios llegamos a la conclusión de que
la gravitación no es en ningún caso una
fuerza
para comprender su naturaleza es
necesario revisar por completo nuestra
comprensión del mundo del universo
entero así como del espacio y del tiempo
esto es lo que llamamos relatividad
general
para su elaboración la relatividad
general se basó casi por completo en el
principio de equivalencia
el principio de equivalencia afirma que
todos los objetos caen de la misma
manera según este principio la caída
libre no es la acción de una fuerza ni
un movimiento acelerado del objeto que
cae por el contrario la caída libre es
el movimiento natural de todas las
entidades
[Música]
entonces cuando los objetos caen sobre
la tierra ello equivale a que éstos
estén en reposo mientras que en realidad
es el suelo el que acelera hacia ellos
[Música]
contrariamente a nuestra inocente
intuición es el acto de caer el que
constituye un movimiento natural una
especie de reposo
mientras que estar inmóvil en la
superficie de la tierra constituye una
constante resistencia a la caída libre y
una permanente aceleración hacia arriba
es por esta razón que solo sentimos
nuestro peso una vez que tocamos el
suelo
durante la caída libre nuestro cuerpo
sigue su movimiento natural y solo al
tocar el suelo sentimos nuestro peso la
acción de nuestros pies frenando la
caída
[Música]
en la relatividad general la gravitación
no es entonces una fuerza
se podría decir que la gravitación no
existe que es algo así como una ilusión
si los objetos de la impresión de caer y
de atraerse
es porque permaneciendo en reposo se
mueven naturalmente en un universo cuya
geometría es curva
así los objetos no se atrae solo se
mueven en línea recta mientras se curvan
el espacio-tiempo a su alrededor como
consecuencia de su masa
esto es lo que influye en las
trayectorias de nuestros objetos
cercanos
la idea más importante de la relatividad
general es que todos los objetos que
poseen una masa deforman el
espacio-tiempo a su alrededor para
entenderlo podemos considerar nuestro
universo como una inmensa red un tejido
de tiempo y espacio por lo que un objeto
masivo tendrá precisamente el efecto de
distorsionar el espacio-tiempo a su
alrededor las nociones de distancia de
dirección o incluso del flujo del tiempo
se ven así distorsionadas alteradas por
la presencia del objeto
naturalmente un objeto tendrá tendencia
a moverse en línea recta por ejemplo si
lanzamos una manzana en medio del vacío
entre galáctico ésta seguirá su
trayectoria en línea recta siempre con
la misma velocidad
pero qué pasaría si las hacemos esta
misma manzana junto un objeto masivo
como la tierra al ser tan masiva la
tierra curva el espacio-tiempo a su
alrededor
las líneas rectas se deforman se curvan
y se entrelazan en la dirección del
planeta
así cuando soltamos la manzana estaba en
línea recta pero como las líneas rectas
han sido deformadas por la masa de la
tierra la manzana se acerca poco a poco
al suelo
este efecto es precisamente lo que
llamamos gravitación
cuando un objeto es muy masivo de forma
la propia estructura del universo que le
rodea curvando las líneas rectas en su
dirección en consecuencia todos los
objetos que le rodean tenderán a seguir
estas líneas curvas y por tanto a
acercarse al objeto
para entenderlo mejor imaginemos
simultáneamente los dos escenarios
siguientes
por un lado los observadores se mueven
en línea recta hacia arriba sobre un
plano el cual no es una superficie curva
por otro lado ambos observadores se
mueven línea recta hacia el norte pero
sobre la superficie de la tierra que es
una esfera por lo que esta vez es una
superficie curva
en el primer escenario para la
superficie plana los dos observadores se
desplazarán en líneas rectas paralelas y
nunca se acercarán el uno al otro
sin embargo en la segunda situación
sobre la superficie de la tierra a pesar
de caminar en línea recta nuestros dos
observadores acabarán encontrándose al
llegar al polo norte
aunque cada uno de ellos ha estado
caminando una perfecta línea recta
debido a la curvatura de la tierra y por
consiguiente al hecho de que las líneas
rectas se curvan en su superficie estas
dos personas sentirán que una misteriosa
fuerza de atracción les hace acercarse
progresivamente el uno del otro
con este ejemplo entendemos mejor cómo
la gravitación puede surgir de la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo
los objetos parecen atraerse y sus
trayectorias parecen encontrarse
progresivamente pero en realidad este
fenómeno se debe a la curvatura de las
líneas rectas a lo largo de las cuales
se mueven los objetos
para ilustrar los fenómenos peculiares
que surgen de la relatividad general
centrémonos en un objeto fascinante de
nuestro universo un agujero negro
un agujero negro es un objeto muy masivo
cuya materia está mayoritariamente
contenida en un único punto ha dicho
punto central lo llamamos una
singularidad gravitacional
en este punto preciso del universo el
tejido del espacio-tiempo se distorsiona
hasta el infinito y la ciencia moderna
no es capaz de comprender del todo lo
que allí ocurre cerca de la singularidad
la curvatura del espacio-tiempo es tan
grande que todas las líneas rectas
apuntan a esta dirección aquí ningún
objeto puede aspirar a escapar del
agujero negro
incluso en el caso de un rayo de luz
todos sus trayectos posibles se dirigen
hacia la singularidad
un agujero negro no emite luz ni la
materia ni la radiación pueden escapar
de él por esta razón lo vemos como una
esfera completamente negra
fuera de esta zona de captura más allá
de este límite que llamamos su horizonte
el agujero negro se comporta como
cualquier otro objeto al acercarnos al
horizonte es imposible permanecer en una
órbita estable alrededor del agujero
negro la distorsión del espacio-tiempo
es excesivamente grande lo que hace que
las trayectorias de los objetos sean
caóticas a esta distancia sin embargo
tan pronto como nos encontremos lo
suficientemente lejos del horizonte como
es el caso de un planeta o una estrella
es posible gravitar de manera estable
alrededor de un agujero negro un objeto
que pase cerca se verá ligeramente
desviado pero podrá seguir escapando de
su atracción en particular los rayos de
luz procedentes de estrellas lejanas
cambian de dirección cuando se aproximan
al agujero negro por esta razón si
observamos un agujero negro de frente
podemos ver una imagen distorsionada de
las estrellas lejanas que en realidad
están detrás de él a esto se le conoce
como lente gravitacional
otro fenómeno interesante surge cuando
el agujero negro gira sobre sí mismo en
el caso de un agujero negro en rápida
rotación este tirará ligeramente el
tejido del espacio-tiempo hacia la misma
rotación un objeto cayendo hacia el
agujero negro desplazándose en línea
recta se desviará así en función de la
rotación del agujero negro
este efecto tan extraño se aplica
también a la tierra cuya rotación sobre
sí misma provoca una ligera desviación
en la caída de los objetos
por último uno de los fenómenos más
destacados es lo que llamamos la
dilatación gravitatoria del tiempo al
encontrarnos cerca de un objeto masivo
como un agujero negro las líneas rectas
que recorremos se distorsionan no sólo
en el espacio sino también sobre todo en
el tiempo el flujo del tiempo se verá
alterado en función de la distancia a la
que nos encontremos del objeto masivo a
una gran distancia del agujero negro el
tiempo transcurre de forma más o menos
similar a la de cualquier otro lugar
sin embargo cuanto más nos acerquemos al
agujero negro más observaremos en
nuestro reloj que el flujo del tiempo se
hace más lento cerca del horizonte el
agujero negro el espacio-tiempo está tan
distorsionado que es posible que por
cada segundo que pase para nosotros pase
un año entero para un observador lejano
en general cuanto más cerca estemos de
una fuente de gravitación es decir de un
objeto masivo como el sol o la tierra
más lento será el paso de nuestro tiempo
propio
si comparamos los relojes internos de
dos observadores uno situado en la base
y otro en la cima de la torre eiffel
vemos que el reloj interno de la persona
que se encuentra abajo es un poco más
lento ya que ésta está más cerca del
centro de la tierra por cada año que
pase la persona que está en la planta
baja de la torre envejecer a un
microsegundo menos que la que esté en la
parte superior
este efecto de dilatación del tiempo es
muy sutil pero extremadamente importante
en la tierra es fundamental tomarlo en
cuenta a la hora de diseñar los
satélites gps de modo que podamos
asegurar la sincronización de los
diferentes relojes internos
en resumen la relatividad general ofrece
un marco completo para entender el
fenómeno de la gravitación
cuando un objeto masivo se encuentra en
el espacio-tiempo distorsiona la
geometría a su alrededor curvando las
líneas rectas en el tiempo y en el
espacio lo que a su vez provoca la
desviación de los objetos circundantes y
modifica así su percepción del tiempo
además de la gravitación la relatividad
general tiene otras consecuencias
sorprendentes
una de ellas es que la distorsión del
espacio-tiempo no es instantánea
al igual que una tela extendida
si un objeto se posa de la nada su
influencia gravitacional tardaría algún
tiempo en propagarse progresivamente por
el espacio y el tiempo curvando la
geometría al universo a medida que
avanza la velocidad de la luz
esta particularidad permite la
existencia de las ondas gravitacionales
fenómenos de distorsión del espacio del
tiempo que se propagan por el universo a
la velocidad de la luz
estas ondas gravitacionales se generan a
años luz de la tierra por eventos
cataclísmicos como la fusión de dos
agujeros negros
pasan a través de nosotros regularmente
distorsionando ligeramente nuestro
planeta y todo lo que hay en él a su
paso
por último esta idea de que nuestro
universo podría tener una geometría
distorsionada plantea la cuestión de su
forma a mayor escala y alimenta
numerosas ideas como por ejemplo la
posible existencia de atajos geométricos
a través del espacio del tiempo todavía
muy especulativos en estos momentos que
llamamos agujeros de gusano
[Música]